DANA PERINO, AND KENNEDY.
"THE FIVE"."
100 LIBERAL RIOTERS SIGNED AN
OPEN LETTER CONDEMNING CASTLE
CULTURE AS AN ATTACK ON FREE
THOUGHT TO WHICH I SAY BETTER
LATE THAN NEVER.
A WISE MAN ONCE SAID EVERY GOOD
DEED COULD’VE BEEN DONE SOONER
SO I APPLAUD THEM FOR JOINING
THE FIGHT FINALLY.
EVEN THOUGH SOME OF THEM, THEY
DIDN’T SEEM TO MIND CANCEL
CULTURE WHEN IT TAKES AIM AT
PEOPLE LIKE YOU OR ME.
IN FACT SOME OF THEM DID TAKE
AIM AT ME BE YOU.
BUT NOW IT’S TARGETING THEM AND
THEY COULD LOSE A BOOK DEAL.
HENCE THE LETTER.
IT’S THE OLD ADAGE THAT LIBERAL
SHOULD HAVE LEARNED BY NOW: YOU
CAN BE NICE TO A CROCODILE BUT
HE WILL STILL EAT YOU.
THE OPEN LETTER IS CUTE BUT WHY
NOT ACTIVELY DEFEND PEOPLE WHO
ARE BEING CANCELED RIGHT NOW?
WHO AREN’T PART OF THIS ELITE
GROUP THAT SIGNED THE LETTER?
WHY NOT HELP THOSE WHO LOST
THEIR JOBS AND NOT JUST SPEAKING
ENGAGEMENTS?
INSTEAD, THEY SAY THEY WANT AND
CANCEL CULTURE BECAUSE ITS
EXISTENCE WILL HELP DRUM.
NO, YOU SHOULD WANT TO END IT
BECAUSE YOU HELPED CREATE IT.
IT ROSE FROM THE TOXIC LOAD OF
ACADEMIA, ENERGIZED BY THE
COWARDICE OF LIBERALS AND MEDIA
POLITICS AND BUSINESS.
THE COUNSELORS CAN SMELL THEIR
FEAR.
IF YOU SAY SOMETHING THEY DON’T
LIKE, THEY WILL CONTACT YOUR
WORKPLACE AND HOW DID YOUR
BOSSES ONLINE UNTIL YOU FINALLY
FIRED.
THE FIRST AMENDMENT MATTERS
LITTLE IF THEY CAN STILL RUIN
YOUR CAREER AND LIFE.
YESTERDAY I ASKED, WHERE’S THE
SILENT MAJORITY?
THE ANSWER: IN HIDING FROM AN
UNSTABLE, ANGRY MOB.
THESE OPEN LETTER WARRIOR SHOULD
FIGHT FOR THEM, NOT JUST FOR
THEMSELVES.
THE PEOPLE WHO MAKE A STUPID
MISTAKE AND LOSE THEIR JOBS,
THEY DON’T HAVE RICH FRIENDS.
I MEAN, WE COULD WIN THIS THING
IF WE FIGHT THIS THING TOGETHER.
IF THE DO IT ALONE, YOU LOSE.
KENNEDY, I LOVED THE LETTER.
IT IS KIND OF BLAND.
I LOVE IT.
THERE’S PART OF ME THAT’S
BOTHERED BY THE FACT THAT THEY
ARE DOING IT NOW BECAUSE THEY
FINALLY FEEL THE HEAT THAT OTHER
PEOPLE HAVE FELT.
>> Kennedy: I WAS WONDERING
WHEN THIS WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
I WAS WONDERING WHEN WE WERE
GOING TO LIVE AT THE POINT WELL
WHILE RABID LEFTISTS WOULD WAKE
UP AND BE REASONABLE FOR A
SECOND.
CANCEL CULTURE KNOWS NO BOUNDS.
IT KNOWS NO PARTY.
IT’S A VERY, VERY HUNGRY BEAST.
AS WE HAVE SEEN COME UP USING IT
DOES NOTHING BECAUSE THERE IS NO
END GAME.
IF YOU HAVE A LIST OF DEMANDS
THAT YOU THINK YOU’RE GOING TO
MEET AND END THE OUTRAGE, THAT’S
NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN.
THEY WILL COME UP WITH NEW ITEMS
ON THAT LIST.
THEY WILL COME UP WITH NEW LISTS
AND NEW ENEMIES AND GUESS WHAT,
IT DOESN’T MATTER IF YOU ARE ONE
OF THE COASTAL ELITES.
THEY ARE COMING FOR YOU.
SO IT’S ABOUT TIME SOMEONE AS A
GROUP STOOD UP FOR FREE SPEECH,
ESPECIALLY THAT WHICH YOU
DISAGREE WITH MOST.
>> Greg: JUAN, IF THEY HAD
ASKED YOU TO SIGN THIS LETTER,
WOULD YOU HAVE?
>> Juan: I’M NOT SURE.
I THINK SO.
I RESIST SORT OF JOINING IN ANY
KIND OF CLUB LIKE THAT.
AND YOU THOUGHT IN TERMS OF THE
RESPONSE FROM SOME ON THE FAR
LEFT HE SAID THESE ARE BEEN WITH
HIGH PAYING JOBS OR JUST WORRIED
ABOUT LOSING THEIR NEXT SPEECH,
THEY ARE NOT SPEAKING OUT FOR
EVERYONE.
GREG, I AGREE FOR THE MOST PART
BECAUSE YOU KNOW, I HAVE BEEN
FIRED FOR SPEAKING MY MIND,
RIGHT?
I HAVE LOST A JOB BECAUSE OF IT.
I LITERALLY WROTE A BOOK CALLED
"MUZZLE THE ASSAULT ON HIS
DEBATE ABOUT THIS."
WHAT’S IRONIC AND WHAT TROUBLES
ME THE REASON I WOULD’VE
HESITATED IT IS I THINK
IDEOLOGICAL DEBATE TODAY IS MORE
OPEN THAN IT’S EVER BEEN IN
LARGE PART BECAUSE WHAT YOUR
VOICE CARRIES, THERE IS A
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM FOR YOU
TODAY.
THOSE VOICES ARE GOING TO GET
HEARD MORE SO THAN EVER BEFORE.
I THINK THAT’S A GOOD THING.
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT CANCEL CULTURE
CULTURE.
IT PLAYS, AS KENNEDY SAID, A
PLACE ON THE LEFT AND RIGHT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP RECENTLY WAS
TRYING TO BLOCK A BOOK BY HIS
KNEES.
TRYING TO BLOCK BOLTON’S BOOK.
>> Greg: THAT IS NOT CANCEL
CULTURE, JUAN.
>> Juan: I THINK IT IS.
YOU’RE TRYING TO SHUT SOMEBODY
UP.
I THINK IF YOU’RE TRYING TO SHUT
PEOPLE UP.
>> Greg: YEAH, I KNOW.
WE HAVE A DELAY.
CANCEL CULTURE TARGETS PEOPLE’S
CAREERS.
IT TRIES TO RUIN THEM.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT A
PERSON WRITING A TELL-ALL BOOK.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT OBSCURE
PEOPLE WHO MAKE A MISTAKE IN
THEIR ENTIRE LIVES ARE
DESTROYED.
IN THIS CASE, THERE IS A GROUP
OF PEOPLE SAYING WE HAVE ENOUGH
AND GRANTED THEY MIGHT BE IMMUNE
TO IT BUT MAYBE THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE THE RIGHT PEOPLE
TO DO IT AT THIS TIME.
>> Dana: RIGHT.
>> Juan: WHAT I THINK IS IF
YOU TRY TO TELL SOMEBODY YOU
CAN’T WRITE THIS BOOK, I DON’T
WANT TO HEAR WHAT YOU HAVE TO
SAY, IF YOU SAY TO A CRITIC, OH,
I THINK YOU’RE A MURDERER, LIKE
HE SAID ABOUT JOE SCARBOROUGH, I
THINK IT’S CANCEL CULTURE.
IT’S A ATTEMPTED SHUT SOMEBODY
UP, TO MUZZLE THEM.
>> Greg: I DISAGREE BUT WE’VE
GOT TO MOVE ON.
>> Juan: LET ME FINISH MY
POINT.
I THINK YOU CAN’T USE THIS TO
EXCUSE PEOPLE WHO WOULD SPREAD
LIES, WOULD HAVE CALLS TO
VIOLENCE, CONSPIRACY THEORIES,
RACISM, ANTI-SEMITISM, SEXISM,
GAY BASHING.
THAT’S NOT WHAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT HERE.
LET’S TALK ABOUT HONEST DEBATE.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, JESSE, YOU
CAN COMMENT ON WHAT JUAN JUST
SAID.
HE PUSHES CANCEL CULTURE OUT TO
ENCAPSULATE A WHOLE BUNCH OF
THINGS.
WHAT SAY YOU?
YOU ARE PROBABLY THE PRIME
TARGET FOR CANCELLATION AT ANY
TIME, PROBABLY BY THE PEOPLE WHO
WROTE THIS LETTER.
>> Jesse: IF THERE WAS A
BETTING POOL ON WHO’S GOING TO
GET CANCELED OFF THIS SHOW, I’D
PROBABLY BE WINNING.
NO, I AGREE WITH YOUR MONOLOGUE.
IT WAS ABOUT SELF-PRESERVATION,
NOT ABOUT PRINCIPLES.
THERE WAS CRICKETS WHEN
REPUBLICANS WERE GETTING SCALPED
LEFT AND RIGHT.
THESE PEOPLE CREATED THE MOB.
THE MOB TURNED ON THEM AND NOW
THEY ARE TRYING TO CHANGE THE
RULES OF THE MIDDLE OF IT TO TRY
TO PROTECT THEIR OWN HIDE.
HE REMINDS ME MONEY OR OTHER
MONOLOGUES WHEN YOU HIGHLIGHTED
THE GUY WHO WAS CHEERING ON THE
RIOTERS UNTIL THE RIOTERS CAME
TO HIS NEIGHBORHOOD AND
BURN HIS NEIGHBORHOOD DOWN AND
THEN HE WAS ON THE PHONE WITH
911 SAYING WHERE ARE YOU.
THEY DO THAT IN THE MIDDLE OF A
GAME TO PROTECT THEIR POWER AND
THEY DO THIS A LOT.
THEY WILL CREATE A MOVEMENT AND
THEN DROP IT WHEN IT’S
POLITICALLY EXPEDIENT.
THEY DID IT WITH CHAS.
THEY DID IT WITH BLACK FACE,
WITH MASKS.
THEY DID IT WITH THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT, THEY’VE DONE IT WITH
THE DEFINED THE POLICE MOVEMENT.
IT’S INTERESTING TO WATCH
BECAUSE THE LEFT IS ALWAYS ON
OFFENSE WHEN IT COMES TO CULTURE
WAR.
THE RIGHT IS ALWAYS ON DEFENSE.
TRUST ME, DEFENSE DOES NOT WIN
CHAMPIONSHIPS BECAUSE IT IS
DEATH BY 1,000 CUTS.
THEY’RE GOING TO THROW
LITIGATION.
THEY’RE GOING TO GET YOU FIRED.
THEY’RE GOING TO HAVE
LEGISLATION.
I MEAN, IT’S JUST A FULL OUT
ASSAULT AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
TRUMP COMES ALONG AND HE PICKS
UP A SWORD AND SAYS LET’S GO ON
OFFENSE, GUYS.
HE STARTS GOING AFTER THE MEDIA.
HE STARTS GOING AFTER THE
DEEP STATE AND THE
ANTI-CHRISTMAS PEOPLE AND THE
STATUE TODDLERS.
WHAT DOES THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
DO?
THEY NOT ONLY DON’T GRAB A SWORD
THEY DON’T EVEN PICK UP A SHIELD
IN DEFENSE.
THEY GO SILENT AND SAT THERE
THIS WHOLE TIME AND THEY HAVEN’T
PARTICIPATED IN THE CULTURE WAR
AND THAT’S NO WAY TO WIN THIS
THING.
>> Greg: GOOD POINT.
DANA, I GOT A LOT OF VIEWERS TO
DEATH OF ME WHEN I WAS TALKING
ABOUT WHETHER THE SILENT
MAJORITY EXISTED.
I GOT A LOT OF EMAILS FROM
PEOPLE SAYING, WHAT WOULD YOU
HAVE US DO?
IF WE AREN’T SILENT, WE WILL
PROBABLY LOSE OUR JOBS.
I THINK THEY ARE REFERRING TO,
THEY TALKED ABOUT SUPPORTING
TRUMP OR WEARING A RED HAT OR
CRITICIZING A MOVEMENT LIKE
BLACK LIVES MATTER, THAT THEY
ARE GONE.
>> Dana: YEAH, AND I
UNDERSTOOD YOUR POINT, AND I
THINK OF COURSE THEY ARE POLITE
AND THEY SEND YOU AN EMAIL AND
THEY SAY BUT WHAT ABOUT US?
I THINK YOU UNDERSTAND THEM AS
WELL BECAUSE YOU’VE SET ON THIS
SHOW BEFORE WE ARE SUPER
PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE ON
"THE FIVE."
WE HAVE A PLACE WHERE WE ARE
FREE TO SAY WHATEVER WE WANT.
WE HAVE BOSSES THAT BACK US UP,
FREE-SPEECH ABSOLUTISTS.
WE ARE IN A MUCH BETTER POSITION
THAN A LOT OF PEOPLE BECAUSE YOU
DO SEE THAT THE CONSEQUENCES OF
SPEAKING UP ARE NOT JUST --
MAYBE YOU HAD A BAD COUPLE
WEEKS.
IT’S THAT YOU ACTUALLY LOSE YOUR
ABILITY TO FEED YOUR FAMILY.
I AGREE WITH JUAN THAT THERE HAS
NEVER BEEN A TIME WHEN YOU COULD
EXPRESS YOUR FEELINGS MORE
OPENLY AND HAVE A DEBATE.
BUT WHAT’S DIFFERENT NOW IS THAT
YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
PEOPLE CALL IF YOUR EMPLOYER AND
DEMANDED HE BE FIRED AND IT’S
VERY HARD FOR ANYBODY TO GET A
JOB AFTER THAT.
REMEMBER THE MOZILLA CEO?
HE HAD GIVEN $1,000 TO PROP
EIGHT, THE ANTI-GAY MARRIAGE
RULE.
REFERENDUM IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT WAS AT THE SAME TIME BARACK
OBAMA EXPRESSLY, THAT WAS HIS
POSITION AT THE TIME AND
EVERYBODY REACHED BACK AND GOT
HIM.
THIS PAST WEEK, BOEING HAD AN
EXECUTIVE WHO LOST HIS JOB FOR
AN ARTICLE HE WROTE 30 YEARS AGO
ABOUT WOMEN IN COMBAT.
IF YOU WENT BACK 30 YEARS AGO
AND YOU LOOKED AT THE GALLUP
POLL, I ALMOST GUARANTEEING YOU
WOULD FIND THAT ISSUE ABOUT
75-25 IN THE COUNTRY AGREEING
WITH HIM.
SO HE ACTUALLY LOST HIS
POSITION.
BOEING LOST AN EXECUTIVE.
HIS FAMILY IS OUT THERE.
THE SAFEST PLACE TO BE WHEN
THERE’S A MOB IS IN THE MOB.
I THINK THAT THIS LETTER IS A
WELCOME THING.
WE SHOULD WANT TO PLAY RED
ROVER, RED ROVER WITH THEM.
LINKED ARMS.
LET’S DO IT.
MY LAST POINT, THERE WAS AN
AUTHOR -- I DON’T KNOW SHE
SIGNED THIS LETTER BUT THE WOMAN
WHO WROTE "AMERICAN DIRT."
I THOUGHT IT WAS A FANTASTIC
NOVEL THAT CAME OUT IN JANUARY
AND THEY CANCELED HER BOOK TOUR
AND NOT BECAUSE HER BOOK SAID
THAT ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
SHOULDN’T COME TO THE COUNTRY.
HER BOOK WAS VERY SYMPATHETIC
AND EMPATHETIC TO THE PLIGHT OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AND WHAT THEY
GO THROUGH.
THE PROBLEM THAT THE COUNSELORS
HAD WAS THAT THEY WERE NOT --
SHE WAS NOT LATINA ENOUGH.
THESE PEOPLE, AUTHORS AND
WRITERS, THEY THINK IT’S GONE
TOO FAR.
WE SHOULD TAKE THEM UP ON IT AND
WORK TOGETHER AND DO WHAT YOU
HAVE TALKED ABOUT WHICH IS TO